Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Nine: Denmark and the Nordic countries.
Many Danes feel that they have particularly strong ties to their Nordic neighbouring countries.
That is because there are significant historical, cultural, political and linguistic similarities between the countries.
People therefore often speak about a kind of "family" of the five Nordic countries: Denmark, Sweden, Norway, Finland and Iceland.
A very visible symbol of this community is that all five countries, with different colour combinations, have the same cross in their flag.
Geography and population.
The four other Nordic countries have a somewhat different geography from Denmark, which makes up a small and relatively densely populated area.
Sweden, Norway, Finland and Iceland are all far bigger, but in return they are Europe's four most thinly populated countries.
These countries generally have a colder climate than Denmark and much larger areas with wild nature, and in several places, especially in Norway, also with mountains.
Sweden, with 10.7 million inhabitants, is the country in the Nordic region with the largest population.
Iceland, with under 400,000 inhabitants, has by far the smallest population, which is thus not much bigger than the population of Aarhus.
Both Norway and Finland, with 5.7 and 5.6 million respectively, have a population almost like Denmark's of 6 million.
History divides and unites.
The Nordic countries' history is to a great extent woven together.
The relationship has, however, not always been harmonious.
The Kalmar Union, 1397 to 1523, which is the only period where the whole of the Nordic region has been politically united, ended with Sweden breaking out after decades of hard fighting.
This was followed by a time, 1563 to 1721, with many big wars between Denmark-Norway on the one side and Sweden on the other about power over the Nordic region and the Baltic Sea.
In Denmark these wars are often called "the Swedish Wars", svenskekrigene.
A painting shows the Swedish siege of Copenhagen in 1658 to 60.
There are also chapters in history that the Nordic populations look back on together with a certain nostalgia.
The Viking Age and the old Nordic mythology, Asatro, are an important common feature in the history of Denmark, Sweden, Norway and Iceland.
At that time the common language, Old Norse, was also spoken, from which the present Danish, Swedish, Norwegian and Icelandic languages have all developed.
The four languages are thus closely related.
Since the Middle Ages, Danish, Swedish and Norwegian, unlike Icelandic, have taken in many words from other languages, first and foremost from German.
The three languages have kept and further developed so many common features that Danes, Swedes and Norwegians can relatively easily read and understand each other's languages.
The majority of the Finnish population has completely different roots from the population in the other Nordic countries, and the Finnish language is therefore very different.
But in Finland both Finnish and Swedish are official languages, and almost all pupils learn both languages in school.
This is because Finland was ruled from Sweden from the 1200s until 1809 and has therefore for a long time been considerably marked by Swedish language and culture, and in addition has a Swedish-speaking minority.
And in Iceland it is also, because of the country's long-lasting connection with Denmark, 1380 to 1944, when Iceland decided by a referendum, folkeafstemning, to become an independent republic, independent of Denmark, common to learn Danish in school as a foreign language.
Thus a certain linguistic connection of all five countries has been preserved.
The Nordic countries all became Christian and professed the Catholic faith in the Viking Age and the Middle Ages.
In connection with the Reformation in the 1500s, the Nordic churches broke with Catholicism and the Pope to instead become Protestant, evangelical Lutheran.
That has been the dominant denomination in the Nordic region to this day.
The Nordic region after 1945.
Since the Second World War, the Nordic countries have especially made themselves noticed by having succeeded both in becoming some of the richest countries in the world and at the same time being among the countries with the greatest economic equality.
People often speak of the Nordic welfare model.
It is characterised, among other things, by the state offering a long series of welfare benefits, for example education, health and elderly care, to all citizens, and by this welfare being paid for jointly by the whole population via taxes and duties.
The countries' foreign policy has had both differences and common features.
Their relationship to the EU and NATO has been different.
Norway and Iceland stand outside the EU, while Finland and Sweden only became members of NATO in 2023 and 2024 respectively.
Conversely all the Nordic countries are known for giving high priority to the UN and international peace work and are also among the countries in the world that give the most in development aid to the poor world.
Further, there is an official Nordic cooperation, which aims to strengthen the political, economic and cultural ties in the Nordic region, for example within environment, culture, research and defence.
They cooperate in the Nordic Council, Nordisk Råd, which consists of politicians from the national parliaments, and in the Nordic Council of Ministers, Nordisk Ministerråd, which consists of ministers from the countries' governments.
The members are Denmark, Sweden, Norway, Iceland and Finland as well as the self-governing areas Greenland and the Faroe Islands, under Denmark, and the Åland Islands, under Finland.
Iceland became an independent republic in 1944.
Here is your recap for Episode Nine.
The five Nordic countries are Denmark, Sweden, Norway, Finland and Iceland, and all have the same cross in their flag.
The four others are Europe's four most thinly populated countries.
Sweden has 10.7 million inhabitants, Iceland under 400,000, Norway 5.7 million, Finland 5.6 million.
The Kalmar Union, Kalmarunionen, from 1397, united the three kingdoms Denmark, Norway and Sweden, and lasted to 1523, the only time the whole Nordic region was united.
The wars between Denmark-Norway and Sweden were 1563 to 1721, called the Swedish Wars.
Old Norse is the common language the Danish, Swedish, Norwegian and Icelandic languages developed from.
Finnish is very different, but Swedish is also an official language in Finland, because Finland was ruled from Sweden from the 1200s to 1809.
In Iceland, Danish is learned at school, because of the connection with Denmark from 1380 to 1944.
After the Reformation the Nordic churches became Lutheran.
Norway and Iceland are outside the EU, while Finland joined NATO in 2023 and Sweden in 2024.
The Nordic Council consists of politicians from the national parliaments, and the Nordic Council of Ministers of ministers from the governments; the members also include Greenland, the Faroe Islands and the Åland Islands.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which three countries formed the Kalmar Union in 1397?
Option A: Denmark, Sweden and England.
Option B: Denmark, Norway and Sweden.
Option C: Denmark, England and Norway.
[DA] Hvilke tre lande dannede Kalmarunionen i 1397?  A: Danmark, Sverige og England  |  B: Danmark, Norge og Sverige  |  C: Danmark, England og Norge
The answer is B: Denmark, Norway and Sweden.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Danmark, Norge og Sverige
Question 2.
When did Iceland decide by a referendum to establish a republic independent of Denmark?
Option A: 1904.
Option B: 1944.
Option C: 1984.
[DA] Hvornår besluttede Island ved en folkeafstemning at oprette en republik, der var uafhængig af Danmark?  A: 1904  |  B: 1944  |  C: 1984
The answer is B: 1944.
It appeared in the November 2020, May 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: 1944
Question 3.
Which wars involving Denmark were fought in the 1600s?
Option A: The Schleswig Wars.
Option B: The England Wars.
Option C: The Swedish Wars.
[DA] Hvilke krige med dansk deltagelse blev udkæmpet i 1600-tallet?  A: De Slesvigske Krige  |  B: Englandskrigene  |  C: Svenskekrigene
The answer is C: The Swedish Wars.
It appeared in the November 2021 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Svenskekrigene
Question 4.
Which religion was the most widespread in Denmark in the Middle Ages, roughly 1050 to 1500?
Option A: Catholic Christianity.
Option B: Protestant Christianity.
Option C: Orthodox Christianity.
[DA] Hvilken religion var den mest udbredte i Danmark i middelalderen (cirka 1050-1500)?  A: Katolsk kristendom  |  B: Protestantisk kristendom  |  C: Ortodoks kristendom
The answer is A: Catholic Christianity.
It appeared in the June 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Katolsk kristendom
Question 5.
What is the Nordic organisation that handles cooperation between the Nordic countries' parliaments called?
Option A: The Nordic Union.
Option B: The Nordtinget.
Option C: The Nordic Council, Nordisk Råd.
[DA] Hvad hedder den nordiske organisation, der varetager samarbejdet mellem de nordiske landes parlamenter?  A: Den Nordiske Union  |  B: Nordtinget  |  C: Nordisk Råd
The answer is C: The Nordic Council, Nordisk Råd.
It appeared in the November 2022, May 2025 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Nordisk Råd
That's the end of this part.
Well done.